la colonie pénitentiaire de marine sq
ces garçons voler tuer ou vendu de la
drogue à 200 km de là tomsk l'une des
trois colonies pour fille en russie
elle aussi purgent des peines lourdes
pour divers crimes en russie environ
17000 délinquants mineurs sont
incarcérés dans soixante deux camps de
travail et de l'éducation
nous sommes en sibérie pour la plupart
des enfants à des milliers de kilomètres
de chez eux
notre équipe est la première à pouvoir
pénétrer à l'intérieur de ces lieux mais
le tournage s'est fait sous étroite
surveillance du fsb successeur du kgb 6
heures du matin réveil dans le dortoir
numéro 4 et premier rappel au saut du
lit
ici les enfants sont entre les mains des
militaires
leur quotidien est régi par une
discipline de fer anatolie a 15 ans il
est là pour avoir volé avec deux copains
moteur de voiture
la justice russe a la main lourde elle
l'a condamné à deux ans et demi ferme
même la petite délinquance est puni
sévèrement surtout quand les délits sont
commis à plusieurs
dans ces colonies tous méritent même la
douche est une récompense accordée une
fois par semaine à quelques privilégiés
les autres doivent se contenter d'un
robinet d'eau froide
dix minutes plus tard un nouvel appel
pour les 324 détenus de marines qu il y
en a une vingtaine par jour dont la
moitié par surprise pour contrecarrer
tout projet d'évasion
arrive le footing matinal torse nu été
comme hiver où les températures tombent
à -40 degrés vague
bonjour uniforme noir offert par l'armée
autrichienne et têtes rasées sont de
rigueur interdiction formelle de bouger
dans les rangs anatolie sort tout juste
d'une mise en quarantaine de deux
semaines un passage obligé traumatisant
pour chaque nouvel arrivant
il en parle en hésitant par peur
d'éventuelles représailles au centre
hospitalier d'autun à tomsk-7 barak
héberge une centaine de filles leur vie
aussi réglé comme du papier à musique
avant la gymnastique matinale
elles ont exactement dix minutes pour
faire leur toilette et ranger le dortoir
larissa 18 ans elle a été condamnée à 5
ans pour complicité de meurtre ça fait
treize mois que l'état tomsk et elle ne
s'y fait pas ici il n'y a pas la moindre
intimité une seule salle de bain pour
tout le maquillage est interdite et s'il
n'ya pas d'uniforme à proprement parler
les filles doivent respecter un code
vestimentaire strict
nous devons être convaincus que chaque
ministre attend
larissa et mère célibataire et elle
n'arrête pas de penser à sa fille de 3
ans xenia depuis sa condamnation elle
n'a pas eu le droit de voir la petite
sa seule consolation ces photos qu'elle
garde comme un trésor
larissa est devenue dépressive
faute de suivi psychologique on lui a
accordé des calmants mais une dispense
pour les activités obligatoires du camp
reste impensable d'ailleurs larissa n'en
veut pas elle espère pouvoir écourté son
séjour par une conduite exemplaire
inspection détenus une cinquantaine de
militaires veillent à ce que le
règlement soit appliqué à la lettre
à leurs côtés des auxiliaires choisis
parmi des détenus modèle aux yeux de la
direction qui leur a accordé une
certaine autorité sur leurs camarades
direction le réfectoire
anatoly komm les autres bagnara droit de
repas par jour essentiellement de la
cache à la traditionnelle bouillie
d'orge du pain noir avec de la margarine
et du thé la direction affirme que ce
menu est très équilibré mais selon les
ong les repas ne couvrirait que 30% des
besoins alimentaires de ces enfants
beaucoup souffriraient de malnutrition
ici on mange en silence sans couteau et
dans le respect du code hiérarchique
entre prisonniers ceux qui sont en bout
de table comme anatolie sont chargés de
servir les autres
ce sont les faibles surnommés les
malsain qui doivent se soumettre au
désir des meneurs un système de castes
pervers sur lequel les éducateurs ont
tendance à fermer les yeux
la minière stade tout ça sous john is
budget
quand philippe iv vase mon genou n'était
pas du vautour à tomsk
c'est l'heure des ateliers de travail
dans les camps tous les déplacements se
font en groupe et à pas cadencés
chen
les filles sont fouillés régulièrement
pour éviter le vol d'outils qui
pourraient servir d'armes
atelier de couture pour larissa elle
confectionne des chemises des tabliers
des robes qui seront vendus dans le
commerce
elle gagne 10 euros par mois un
privilège qui lui permet de s'acheter
des produits comme du savon du
dentifrice dans le magasin de la colonie
mais c'est surtout pour elle la seule
chance d'apprendre un métier qu'elle
pourra exercer plus tard tout le monde
n'a pas le droit à une telle formation
les places sont rares et réservés aux
plus méritants
les voitures
thomas
et arrête aux cobras technologies
l'organisme
la santé
m
dans les ateliers aussi la surveillance
ne connaît aucune relâche pourtant l'une
milla makarova l'éducatrice en chef se
montre de temps en temps moins sévère
après 18 ans de service
elle éprouve une certaine compassion
pour ses filles
la platine du bâtiment
l'éducatrice en chef nous emmène dans le
lieu le plus redouté par les
prisonnières le mitard dans ces cellules
d'isolement sont envoyés les filles qui
refusent de se soumettre une prison dans
la prison
elles peuvent passer jusqu'à 12 mois je
te salir un chat
à des cours d'éducation civique pour le
groupe d'anatolie la plupart d'entre eux
ne savent ni lire ni écrire
les colonies sont censés pallier leur
manque d'instruction et tous les moyens
sont bons y compris les préceptes en
virus datant de l'époque du tsar pierre
le grand
les gars ont du mal à suivre
ou tout simplement du mal à comprendre
de toute façon ces recommandations de
bonne conduite d'un autre temps ne les
concerneront jamais
il vous parlez du monde - quatre f-16 a
dit hé ben ammar inc
les privilégiés ont le droit de
travailler à la briqueterie pour 10
euros par mois
une tâche physiquement dur mais très
prisé par les détenus
malheureusement cet apprentissage
rémunéré dépend des commandes
extérieures de plus en plus rares
les entreprises russes privatiser ne
sont plus contraintes de se fournir dans
ces camps
une situation qui aggrave les problèmes
budgétaires des colonies
marines qui doit fonctionner avec une
aide d'état modeste trop limité pour
éduquer former ou simplement occuper
tous les détenus
alors on fait avec les moyens du bord
la tonte de la pelouse à la main en fait
partie
evgeny sort du mitard où il a passé deux
semaines pour avoir fumé un joint
on lui a retiré son poste à la
briqueterie six mois avant sa libération
sa réinsertion dans la société est
compromise car il ne recevra pas
d'attestation de formation en
comptabilité d'abonnés dont j'avais été
bizarrement cette action il ya un an ou
deux phrases à soyaux dania bout du
chemin du mans moto qui est ainsi bien
y'a katusha ce drame au total on se
présente phrases toutes ces petites
chine
john gadret sastre n'a pas pu tenir sous
john deere vous à nous ce match est très
juste te plait j'achete âge tout mon
soûl brunch ce boulet mercure mire une
quinzaine au total sept dates et
horaires 7 079 en justice ce jeune miens
la russie compte un million de détenus
adultes et mineurs confondues un quart
des familles déplorent un ou plusieurs
de ses membres en prison c'est le cas de
vadim 18 ans il purge à marines qu'une
peine de trois ans pour trafic de drogue
et vol aujourd'hui lui le petit sergei
profite d'une permission exceptionnelle
pour rendre visite à leur mère le hasard
fait qu'elles sont détenus toutes les
deux dans une prison pour femmes à
seulement 20 km d'ici
bien d'un roi baudouin à daytona but
c'est de la faute à un stade bien et
pousse patrick thomas
vadim n'a pas vu sa mère depuis deux ans
ils appréhendent ces retrouvailles et la
présence des gardiens le met mal à
l'aise
tant mieux
il est trop gêné pour serrer sa mère
dans ses bras
j'ai conduit
à partir de maintenant le temps est
compté vadim et sergei au moins d'un
quart d'heure pour s'entretenir avec
leur mère est due au choc
longtemps les instituts
la rencontre riche en émotions s'est
bien passé les deux rentrent à la
colonie plutôt rassuré ni le queer
straka et au village c'est sûr pas la
couleur
le père alexander nouveaux cas d'offre
officie une fois par semaine à marines
qu il est très sollicité par les garçons
pour qui la religion est devenue un
exutoire à la dureté de leur condition
car ce stand est organisé les votants je
te souhaite notamment des dangers qu en
minéraux et nous y est catholique
adressé à stopper lycée général
pas si vite mais ce dernier estime
aujourd'hui qu'elle avait tiré sur
l'indicible attaque investisseurs
chaque mois le père nouveau k9 baptise
une dizaine de détenus
les demandes de confessions sont telles
qu'il n'arrive presque pas y faire face
des enfants dont on ne sait s'il
recherche dieu ou simplement une oreille
attentive à leur détresse est grave
what she hate chaude
cette chaude et chercheur tuba et est
traqué le dictateur canada suits
l'outaouais a tant rêvé ce problème a
confié pascal buchet minute d'un accord
a tranché casta wasquehal 3 buts en
comptant sur un terrain du cij
vera et psychologues
l'administration lui a confié les filles
est séropositive du camp dont on ne sait
pas quoi faire
ont elles sont quinze ce sont des parias
de la colonie on les maintient
totalement à l'écart des autres
je crois et je vous restez sa piste et
la route pour la plupart de ses filles
séropositives sont d'anciennes drogués
qui sont tombés pour trafic de
stupéfiants albiana 15 ans elle a pris
trois ans ferme
comme pour
j'étais à tomsk aucun traitement n'est
disponible pour les séro positive on
leur accorde seulement un régime
alimentaire légèrement amélioré en
vitamines et en produits laitiers et
verra bien que psychologue ne leur offre
aucun autre soutient que des séances de
relaxation
vous connaîtrez de shérif continue de
mahmoud al thani est apparu
partout comment je me steeve montagne et
vitamine e pons un rituel dans mon
projet revenir à mon niveau de jeu
non ne tombent pas malades tamara dit ne
pas comprendre ni bon sur moins dix
minutes au croisement je les tiens
fin d'après-midi à marines qu 1h30 de
récréation durant leur détention la
majorité des garçons ne recevra aucune
visite de leur famille
pour les parents la sibérie est trop
loin et le voyage trop cher ne reste que
le courrier pour maintenir le contact
mais un atelier lui n'a plus personne
avec qui correspondent
nombreux travaux les mois s'annoncent
soyez par tout ce qui semble qu'au
football farmer qui sirotaient mike
keane doublons copains tu en as mio chf
le ministère de la justice à moscou nous
a ouvert exceptionnellement les portes
de tomsk et marines les colonies
présentable amnesty international fait
état dans son dernier rapport des cas de
maltraitances de tortures et de viols et
dénoncent un manque criant de structures
d'apprentissage et d'éducation digne de
ce nom
tout aussi inquiétant le taux de
récidive de 80% pour presque tous ces
jeunes le passage dans une colonie
marque le début d'une vie derrière les
barreaux